Trascrizione: Lisa Cobello
Revisore: Chiara Polesinanti
Buonasera.
C'è un video che cerca di dare un senso
al pensiero che cerco di sostenere
davanti a tutta questa gente;
quindi fermalo qui,
ferma già qui,
perché questo è veramente...
Noi abbiamo due o tre pensieri
che ci danno il cammino da seguire.
Mi piace dire la stella polare
perché la stella polare è quella cosa
che il navigatore vede e segue,
sa che non la raggiungerà mai,
però non importa, è indispensabile
perché ci vuole una visione
magari irraggiungibile.
Una delle nostre stelle polari,
quella che ci accompagna da sempre
la nostra stella polare,
cioè che i pensieri prendono forma.
Piccoli, sottili pensieri prendono forma.
È una frase
che si può leggere in tanti modi.
Si può leggere in una maniera
più sottile e in una più tecnica.
Per adesso leggiamolo in maniera tecnica.
Cos'è che prende forma?
Riparte il video.
[Piccoli sottili pensieri
prendono forma depositandosi]
Vediamo che questo piccolo insetto
che è la vespa vasaia
sta costruendo una casa,
un rifugio.
Ferma.
È veramente incredibile,
questa è una stampante 3D.
Chi non avesse mai visto
una stampante 3D sa che cos'è questo.
Questo insetto ha cambiato la nostra vita
perché proprio osservandolo
e stupiti di dire:
"Ma guarda come fa a costruire!",
in un momento in cui stavamo cercando
di costruire una stampante 3D
la vespa vasaia è stato un pensiero
che si è depositato nella mente
e ha preso forma poi tanti anni dopo.
Continua il video.
[Motivazione come risultato]
Ferma.
Un altro dei pensieri che ci guida
è che la motivazione è già un risultato.
Ho passato una vita
da piccolo imprenditore e artigiano,
mi piace dire "smanettone" di professione
perché nella mia zona, chi smanetta e fa
si chiama "smanettone",
chi ama fare le cose.
Vivendo di questo,
dopo una vita passata a lavorare,
amando quello che si faceva
è nato questo pensiero chiaro,
che quello che importa
è una grande motivazione,
un grande pensiero e visione
perché questo è già un risultato
indipendentemente da quello che succederà.
Potrebbe anche andare bene
il lavoro, o andare male,
aver successo, oppure no,
ma se la motivazione è grande,
quello è già un risultato.
Ecco che da qui è nato il nostro gruppo -
vai avanti -
che si chiama WASP.
Ferma.
Ha come simbolo la vespa vasaia
che è un acronimo che si prende in giro.
"World Advanced Saving Project"
Immaginate un gruppo
di ragazzotti e di artigiani
che decide di affrontare uno dei problemi
del mondo, che è quello della casa.
Nei prossimi 30 anni,
dai tre ai quattro miliardi di persone,
un miliardo di persone sono
più di tutte quelle che sono ora in Africa
quindi quattro volte l'Africa,
hanno bisogno di casa
e hanno un reddito medio di 3.000 dollari
e si valuta che possano spendere
il 10% nella casa
Quindi come costruire una casa
che costa circa 300 dollari?
Questo è il tema che ci siamo dati
come ricercatori indipendenti e visionari
e ci siamo chiamati WASP
per il modello di sviluppo
che ci ha insegnato la vespa vasaia.
Si prende quello che c'è sul posto
e lo si deposita,
il sole cambia forma e stato,
da fluido a solido, la materia,
Ricomincia il video.
È chiaro che per fare cose
bisogna andare sul fare.
Qui eravamo nel 2012,
parliamo di tre o quattro anni fa.
Ferma.
Qui eravamo già avanti,
avevamo già fatto una prima stampante
usando tutti i pezzi riciclati,
motori da vecchie stampanti
un pezzo d'estrusore,
era una pistola per estrudere il silicone
comprata al supermercato.
Però grazie alla conoscenza collettiva
avevamo scaricato dei software
che ci permettevano di depositare
materiale in maniera controllata.
Potevamo disegnare oggetti e dargli forma
passando dal PC alla materia.
Era già una gioia per noi
vedere queste cose che venivano fuori.
Era forte la motivazione,
quindi comunque sarebbe andata
sarebbe stato un grande successo
perché era bello lavorare per questo.
Continua il video.
Come vedete è un bel sistema scalcinato
che ci collegava anche al fare concreto
perché mentre si progettava
si doveva pensare:
"Come sarà fatto in realtà
quando lo faremo più grande,
come depositeremo la materia,
come trasporteremo il materiale?".
Era una ricerca reale su due fronti,
uno un po' visionario, uno un po' tecnico.
Ferma.
Anzi, continua ancora
e ferma un po' più avanti.
Si vede qualcosa
che per noi è stato importante.
Puoi fermare.
Ad un certo punto
ci servivano anche dei soldi.
All'inizio ci siamo mossi
con i pezzi trovati in giro
un po' di passioni e di amici.
Poi ci servivano anche dei soldi.
Come facciamo a finanziare
un progetto del genere?
Devo dire la verità,
sono anche andato in banca.
(Risate)
Sono anche andato in banca.
Non vi racconto com'è andata,
ma si può immaginare.
Tornando a casa però non ci si arrende
se l'obiettivo è grande.
Uno comincia a pensare,
e l'idea è stata questa, per me è furba.
Noi vogliamo costruire questa stampante,
ormai era chiara nella mente com'è fatta
sono tre assi verticali
perché la possiamo ingrandire
la possiamo scalare,
il software e l'hardware sono questi
ma ne costruiamo una piccola
e la vendiamo
e vendendo quella,
finanziamo il progetto.
Però la vendiamo dicendo
che la stampante vuole farne una grande
vuole risolvere uno dei problemi
del mondo, che è la casa.
Ecco che usando il sogno, il progetto,
la visione come metodo promozionale
per vendere le stampanti piccole
e utilizzando le stampanti piccole
per realizzare, per costruire il progetto,
abbiamo creato un circolo economico
e di promozione che ha funzionato
e sta tutt'ora funzionando.
Vai pure avanti.
Abbiamo iniziato a produrre stampanti.
Eravamo sette "smanettoni",
come mi piace chiamarci
adesso siamo in 20 che lavoriamo fissi
più altri 20 come collaboratori esterni.
Ferma un attimo.
Mi sorprendo quando il commercialista
mi dice che siamo un'azienda
perché a tutti gli effetti
siamo diventati un'azienda,
ma quasi sorprendendoci.
Abbiamo sviluppato sistemi di estrusione
per depositare materiali fluido-densi,
quindi porcellana e ceramica.
E tutte le volte il progetto
era questo di stampare le case,
ma per arrivare là si creavano prodotti
più piccoli, che venivano venduti.
Attualmente vendiamo
stampanti per porcellana.
Siamo forse tra i primi,
non voglio esagerare,
ma credo che siamo forse i primi
che vendono un prodotto
per stampare porcellana nel mondo.
Quindi il progetto, la visione,
la nostra stella polare
in realtà ci apre dei mercati,
scopriamo dei prodotti
che nascono spontaneamente
perché noi volevamo salvare
il mondo, ci piace dire,
però che importa,
l'importante è avere quella visione
e veramente cercare
di fare qualcosa di buono.
Poi, quello che viene, verrà.
Le stampanti crescono,
facciamo stampanti 3D.
Vai col video.
Gli oggetti stessi che vendiamo
sono prodotti con le stampanti;
quindi autoproduzione a tutti gli effetti,
dove la stampa della porcellana cresce
e tutti gli anni raddoppiamo la dimensione
delle macchine che riusciamo a costruire.
L'idea è quella di costruire una casa,
quindi la macchina è importante,
ma non ci siamo buttati su quel progetto
bensì sul fare quotidiano.
Avere un grande progetto
e lavorare nel piccolo.
Sviluppando i sistemi
di estrusione ed estrusori,
avendo bene in mente il modello
che vogliamo raggiungere,
che è la famosa vespa vasaia.
Qui puoi fermare.
Si vede come rappresenta
ancora il progetto
e come segue
da sempre il nostro sviluppo.
Riparti col video.
Questo modo di procedere ci ha portato
a vedere le case di terra nel mondo.
Abbiamo scoperto che, nel mondo,
ci sono tantissime case di terra.
Puoi continuare.
Qui siamo andati a Aït Ben Haddou,
che è una città del Marocco
dove da sempre tutto è fatto di terra,
e in questa città abbiamo imparato,
abbiamo parlato con le persone
per farci spiegare
come stavano nella casa,
per capire come si comportava
la casa con l'acqua,col vento.
Qui non c'è solo il sole,
ma anche la pioggia forte.
Si vedono delle immagini
dove c'è anche neve.
Quindi è un clima molto vario.
Abbiamo stampato
alla biennale di Marrakesh,
con la terra di Aït Ben Haddou,
delle forme,
perché il concetto è crescere
ed è importante mantenere la visione.
Non importa cosa succederà
o quanto tempo ci metteremo
e ci siamo scoperti
in un'economia dell'autoproduzione.
Maker economy è questo.
Vai pure col video.
Maker economy è autoprodursi le cose.
Normalmente si cerca lavoro
in un'industria o in una fabbrica;
in un approccio di maker economy
si autoproducono i propri progetti.
Questi sono gli estrusori che vendiamo,
prodotti con le nostre stampanti
quindi le stampanti diventano
delle piccole fabbriche in miniatura
che permettono la costruzione
di ulteriori prodotti.
Abbiamo sviluppato stampanti
per fare gioielleria
o banali stampanti
per fare pezzi di ricambio.
Questa è anche un cosa interessante.
Ferma un attimo.
Qui parliamo di intelligenza
e di conoscenza collettiva.
Un ragazzo americano ha sviluppato
un sistema di immobilizzazione.
Un laboratorio del Politecnico di Milano,
il +LAB, l'ha preso e messo in risalto.
Noi abbiamo dato un altro contributo
e l'abbiamo stampato su un piano caldo.
Per cui...
Vai.
Questo è un sistema
di immobilizzazione provvisoria
che sarà una risposta ai gessi
perché è traspirante, a basso costo,
perché non ci sono magazzini
o scorte di magazzino.
Ecco che il dentale è un altro settore
che si può coprire con la stampa 3D.
Come vedete, è il food l'ultimo punto
che è una ricerca che stiamo facendo.
Qui siamo al confine della fantasia.
Ma il produrre...
Questi sono giardini verticali
che stiamo progettando
per essere stampati,
che, assieme alla casa,
potranno diventare una vera economia.
Ora mi sono accorto che ho sforato
e quindi devo chiudere.
Mi scuso...
Ci sarà l'immagine della grande stampante
di 12 metri che stampa.
Vi invito a vederla
nei prossimi giorni da noi.
(Applausi)